[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a binary world un juego de
simulación de la realidad donde podéis
elegir quién querés ser
para cumplir con el objetivo de la
especie que es procrear y tener hijos
infinitamente
para ello podemos crear un nuevo
personaje y elegir entre estos fabulosos
personajes
creamos una nueva
tenemos tan tan tan tan tan tan hombre
tal vez esta mujer tan tan tan tan para
igual estas estas son todas las opciones
que hay
elijamos mujeres porque me gustan los
desafíos
ahora elegir un vestido de novias porque
el objetivo del juego es procrear la
especie y no lo vamos a hacer si no está
casada claro hay que hacerlo como se
debe a ver cuál me gusta más
me parece que el primero parece tener
más caderas cosas que puede cargar más
hijos
vamos con este
ahora su marido hay que tener mucho
cuidado porque es una elección para toda
la vida ojo
para ver cuál me gusta más el primero
tiene pinta de más proveedor con celular
en la mano parece que no se le va a ir
mucho la mente a otros pensamientos
libidinosos y yo solamente va a querer
procrear como se debe resguardarse para
esto
ahora elijamos un nombre
qué nombre tenemos
son todos medio viejos estos nombres tal
y sofía
queremos un nombre más joven más fresco
así tienen los más frescos no es mucho
más seguro mejor
muy bien ya se está creando la familia
ahora bueno qué bueno parece que van a
formar una excelente familia y la mujer
va a ser fiel a su marido va a cumplir
con todas las tareas del hogar va a
limpiar la casa va a cuidar a sus hijos
hasta que se muera qué felicidad
y bueno esto parece que van a van a
durar por toda la vida espero
ay bien menos más así también sus hijos
lo hacen y los hijos de los hijos los
visillos todos infinitamente el mundo
ideal
y bueno todo el mundo tiene que
compartir esta misma visión porque si no
el mundo se desmorona
muy bien el objetivo del juego es tener
la mayor cantidad de hijos posibles
intenta superar a estos jugadores
la familia está lista a ver el resultado
al que bella familia
ese niño tiene senos
por favor aguarden estamos teniendo
problemas técnicos
bueno me están comunicando que debemos
devolverlos a la a la vida real
iniciando retorno
bienvenidos a la vida real
en el juego de la vida podemos elegir
quién queremos ser
para cumplir con nuestras propias metas
y lograr lo que nos propongamos como
mejor nos sintamos
para esto cada mañana cuando nos
despertamos elegimos que ponernos qué
actitud tener para encarar con nuestro
día
es un juego que vivimos todos los días y
tenemos que jugar las cartas que tenemos
para sentirnos más cómodos
y para esto
para el salir a la calle nos topamos con
otros jugadores que también van a estar
expresando su actitud su prendas todo y
esto va a tener un género un género
arraigado a esta imagen vivimos en una
sociedad donde todo lo que somos todo lo
que vemos se le asigna a un cierto valor
una característica ya que es necesario
para formar una visión común donde una
realidad de una sociedad y poder así
en entendernos en común y relacionarnos
así que acompañan a crear un nuevo
personaje pero sin las limitaciones del
juego anterior porque en el mundo real
hay un montón más de posibilidades
lo primero que se define es el sexo
cromosómico
cuando el espermatozoide cuando el mamá
papá se quiere mucho
en principio
hay información genética que se junta
que
contiene sea un cromosoma y información
para desarrollar un pene y testículos y
el x que no lo contiene en general
llamamos a individuos xx hembras
individuos x 6 machos pero hay muchos
casos en los que la información el gen
que se encuentra en el cromosoma y no
expresa esta información y por ende no
se llegan a desarrollar un pene y
testículos y la persona resulta hembra
así como
una x una x x puede tener esta
información también por una mutación y
también hay un montón más de
posibilidades de mezclas en juande de
duplicación del cromosomas y estas
personas se llaman intersexuales y
forman aproximadamente el 2% de la
población
como los pelirrojos
pero igual no decimos que sólo hay
rubios y morochos
ahora elijamos por ejemplo xy
muy bien después está el sexo genital
tenemos pene o vagina también adopciones
en el medio pero las personas
intersexuales en general en el
nacimiento son sometidas a una cirugía
por parte de los padres para elegir el
sexo que quieren que tenga
esto en general es muy nocivo porque las
personas puede ser que no no se sientan
cómodas con esos genitales que
decidieron por ellas más adelante
ahora elijamos como pene por por ejemplo
también puede tener genitales internos
tanto como no por decisión propia o por
naturaleza ahora vamos con una opción
convencional
muy bien
ahora bien en sexo hormonal tenemos la
testosterona que es producida por los
testículos y hace que el cuerpo se vea
se desarrolle de una manera así la grasa
y los músculos se adaptan para tomar una
forma similar a ésta también se puede
suplir y tomarme de forma externa por
medicación para suplir las que ya
producen o de las que
o suprime una falta de hormonas en el
cuerpo
y el estrógeno hace que el cuerpo se vea
de una forma similar a esta a esta ahora
elijamos que esta persona tenga
testosterona en su cuerpo
muy bien tenemos una persona xx sin
combine testículos y testosterona
bueno un hombre piensan
ahí está el tema que es un hombre
el problema es que al pene lo pintaron
de azul
al concepto de hombres se le ha asignado
un montón de valores y características
en la sociedad ya no es una cuestión
solamente de portar con estas
características biológicas porque no sos
un hombre de verdad sino cumplir con
ciertas características o no sos un
hombre a los ojos de la otra persona si
lúcida así por ejemplo
pero para el caso cuando se viene cuando
se refiere a la biología de nuevo se
caen en lo que es un hombre pero un
hombre como dije tiene un montón de
características cada persona y idea una
propia una propia visión del género
ex y lo espera en la otra persona
pero acá vemos que hay un cuadro de
texto
esto es porque el género no es más que
una etiqueta para definir como mejor nos
sentimos
por qué
hombre
biológicamente tal vez se puede referir
así pero hombres socialmente en mi caso
no soy
yo soy una mujer trans soy una mujer no
por educación sino por elección yo elegí
portar estas características
y me sale naturalmente la feminidad y la
expresión de ella
hace que se considere una persona mujer
por ende y porque es por elección soy
una mujer trans
y tiene estas cosas
cuándo
cuando elegí ser trans cuando elegís una
identidad de género que no es la que se
espera de tu biología
la gente ya deja de verte por lo que
realmente sos por ejemplo vamos a una
entrevista de trabajo
el entrevistador lo que en un hombre
puede ver como perseverancia como
determinación que en una mujer ve como
bueno mando neo en una persona trans ve
una persona trans muchas veces se quedan
en esa en ese límite y no lo pueden
trascender
esto nos dificulta en muchos otros
aspectos imagínense
al conocer un hombre por ejemplo qué
no quieran ser vistos con voz en la
calle porque tu identidad
les da vergüenza es algo que no es común
y porque también tienen miedo de ser
llamados homosexuales cuando la
heterosexualidad no es más que una
atracción hacia lo femenino
esto hace que la vida se nos dificulta
bastante y sobre todo porque
nos violentan nos matan nos limitan
constantemente en la vida las
posibilidades que tenemos
simplemente por el hecho de expresarnos
como somos
ahora la expresión de género que no es
lo mismo que la identidad de género
porque una persona puede ser masculina o
femenina y eso no deja de hacerla un
hombre una mujer
en mi caso yo soy bastante masculina
tengo me decido mantener mi pelo corto
tengo rasgos angulosos también puedo
[Música]
que todo eso que bastante hombre pero no
son cosas masculinas así como lo puede
hacer una mujer y no deja de ser una por
hacerlo entonces yo por extensión
también
aunque seguramente si me pongo ratón si
me pongo una camisa de cuadritos tal vez
piensen que soy lesbiana
pero esto en general se piensa así por
ver un estereotipo de género que en
realidad no tiene nada que ver porque la
sexualidad es una vivencia muy personal
que vamos construyendo con nuestras
experiencias
en mi caso bueno no soy lesbiana alguna
una chica bueno puede ser yo soy bien
entero pero una boca es una boca
así que digamos que me considero hetero
flexible
[Risas]
para no renegar de mi heterosexualidad
muy bien ahora solo falta nombrar me y
yo soy mi propia obra de arte me
construí a mí misma con cirugías
mediante todo lo que vivo lo construyó
lo tomó y crezco con eso y voy formando
mi identidad en base a esto y por eso yo
elijo
yo elijo ser la alejandra
y ustedes eligieron quiénes son
[Aplausos]
[Música]